why were you having the was it a deep
tissue massage you were having where are
you going with this green having a
Turkish massage or something I don't
know what it has to do with what we're
talking about
sorry tell it I had an awful experience
in the Turkish massage where this guy's
idea of massage was to like take my one
leg and and the other arm and try and
connect it behind my back and I was kind
of like you know like that and then I
will his belly went in my mouth and you
know when you get something weird in
your mouth and you're like if you're
eating something you go like you send
your brain send your tongue to figure
out what it is
gonna conscious god it's just like is
that a bomb figure that
to figure it out my tongue was like what
is that
it's a hairy belly it's like you're
heading off for newspapers
Michael such a low point you [__]
loser